I think there's also fundamentally a
major misunderstanding of China in this
country say more and I let me tell you
what the major misunderstanding is you
all you've seen that China was ruled by
Communist Party in 1949 a common rule by
Communist Party 1979 it'd be ruled by
Communist Party 2019 and you assume that
China hasn't changed it's still being
run by the same Communist Party but the
Chinese Communist Party has obviously
changed fundamentally I mean from and I
I went to China for the first time in
1980 when I went to China for the first
time in 1980 the Chinese people couldn't
didn't have the freedom they couldn't
choose what to wear they all wore Maori
suits they couldn't choose where to live
where to work what to study
then suddenly zero Chinese could travel
overseas zero now you go back to China
the Chinese people can choose what to
wear where to live where to work where
to study and guess what every year
hundred and twenty million Chinese right
I think it's more than popular in
California 120 million Chinese leave
China freely as tourists amazingly 120
million Chinese returned to China freely
now if China was a communist gulag
Stalinist state would you go back to
China and so there's a complete
misunderstanding of China clearly there
while the political freedoms in China
have an increase the personal freedoms
of the Chinese people has exploded and I
can tell you one of the one of the
questions that future historians will be
very puzzled by is the judgments made by
America on China and I tell you why they
be Puzzle the United States of America
is about 240 years old Chinese history
maybe 2400 years old in today's world
you have a society which is 240 years
old passing judgment on a society which
is 2400 years old and at a time when
China has had its best 30 years of
history the Americans are telling
Chinese you guys are not doing very well
really you should change your political
system listen to us become a democracy
all we well with you and I can tell you
one thing that Chinese leaders there's a
whole shades of opinion among them the
one complete point of agreement that
they all have is that they saw what
happened to the Soviet Communist Party
they saw what happened to the Soviet
Union they saw what happened to Russia
he went overnight to a democracy guess
what the Russian economy imploded life
expectancy came down infant mortality
went up the Russian people suffered and
the Chinese said this is what happens
when you have an instant democracy so
when the Chinese said give us time let
us transform our political system in our
own will I said let them do it why do
you think that you would know better
what's good for them does that reflect
the fact
that for 200 years you got used to doing
it telling the world how they should
behave and therefore you think you can
be a better judge of the rest of the
world so that judgmental character in
the West has got to adapt to a rest of
the world because the rest of the world
today is less willing to be judged by
you